Welcome back everyone happy new year if
you're watching this video you made it to
2021 congratulations you survived 2020 this is
going to be my video all about the mandalorian
and luke skywalker meeting ahsoka tano if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes i will be doing videos for all
the mandalorian and spin-off series and the
other star wars series that they've announced all
year long we have three new star wars series that
are dropping episodes this year so there's going
to be way more stuff going on obviously careful
for spoilers for everything that's happened during
the mandalorian so far if you haven't seen all the
episodes yet but after the ahsoka tano and luke
skywalker episodes of the mandalorian season 2 a
lot of you were asking if ahsoka tano knew luke
skywalker or had ever met him anywhere in the
timeline so this video will explain their relative
history together and how jon favreau and dave
filoni are changing things for the better that's
kind of what they're doing with the mandalorian
series all these spin-off series like the ahsoka
tano episodes that dave filoni is currently
writing right now those will be filming later this
year with rosario dawson's ahsoka tano making the
entire story of star wars better with all the new
interactions between all these big main characters
because of course ahsoka tano would meet luke
skywalker at some point that would be one of
the most amazing scenes ever but originally before
they'd ever thought to do the mandalorian series
before any of those brand new characters that they
didn't pluck out of the animated series had been
written into the canon like before they created
the grogu and mando characters ahsoka tano had
canonically never met luke skywalker between the
events of his birth during revenge of the sith and
the rise of skywalker ending scene in the new
movies where you hear ahsoka tano's voice with
the voices of all the other jedi and by the way
a couple years ago right after the movie came out
dave filoni posted about that implying that just
because most of the jedi's voices who you heard
during that scene were dead were force ghosts that
didn't mean that ahsoka tano was also dead there
were a lot of things about that movie that didn't
make sense so just forget about all that stuff
not really important it's just that she's still
alive 30 plus years into the future during that
era it's just that she's in our late 60s and
70s when that's happening right now during
the events of the mandalorian rosario dawson's
version of ahsoka tano is in the early to mid
40s which is still pretty young rosario dawson
just hasn't aged that much in the last 20 years
which is why this version of ahsoka still seems
relatively young but she's about 17 to 18 years
older than luke skywalker just for reference luke
is meant to be in his late 20s when this scene is
happening during the finale he was born right at
the end of revenge of the sith and ahsoka tana was
almost 18 years old when order 66 was happening
the main reason before the mandalorian series why
ahsoka had not met luke though is that after
revenge of the sith in order 66 she went into
hiding like obi-wan and yoda told all remaining
jedi that could hear their signal please do not
contact anyone go to ground hide in before their
last meeting prior to mustafar and him getting
cooked like crispy chicken he never told ahsoka
about the secret of padme being pregnant with the
twins they kind of addressed this during the
clone wars season 7 episodes last year where
they were doing the star wars version of a zoom
call and you see her with a really swollen belly
he's been hiding all his communications from
obi-wan and the rest of the jedi council
even though they reveal that obi-wan knew about
their relationship the whole time so anakin never
had the chance to tell ahsoka that there was even
a possibility that he might have children someday
so after she went into hiding for several years
after order 66 she wouldn't have had a reason
to seek out luke or leia in obi-wan to his credit
never subsequently contacted her to tell her about
it because he didn't know where she was she was so
good at hiding in the outer rim and he didn't know
whether or not she was still alive even he also
probably didn't want to chance the secret getting
back to darth vader and emperor palpatine so while
luke is busy growing up on tatooine bulls-eying
womp rats with his t-16 ahsoka is running from the
empire and darth vader's inquisitors in the outer
rim territories eventually bale organa learns that
ahsoka is still alive in the very earliest days of
the rebellion way before the events of star wars
rebels and he recruits her to their cause and she
just takes the secret identity fulcrum she helps
the rebels out but staying mostly in the distant
parts of the outer rim territories and she's
nowhere near tatooine so obi-wan at this point
still doesn't know about her still being alive
and she still doesn't know that anakin's children
exist then the events of star wars rebels happen
she has her big reunion fight with darth vader
and even though everybody's getting crazy force
visions darth vader has sith force visions of her
and she has forced visions of him neither of them
learned about the secret of his children still
being alive even though he got forced visions of
luke skywalker as an adult before he knew that
luke existed so he didn't know that he was looking
at his son when he was getting these forced
visions ezra bridger uses the star wars equivalent
of time travel to pluck ahsoka out of the timeline
from the sith temple that's right time travel
exists canonically in the star wars universe
using the world between worlds it's like a nexus
in the force that exists out of normal space time
and you have all these portals that will take you
to different parts of the timeline ahsoka goes on
jedi walkabout in the outer rim during the events
of the original trilogy of movies so there's a
lot of this untold story during that period of her
life they'll probably fill in some of those blanks
during the ahsoka tano mandalorian spin-off series
in those episodes and during that period she's
so off the radar and out of communication with
everyone that she doesn't learn about the rebels
blowing up the first death star and the second
death star till well after they happen like oh by
the way the emperor is dead oh that's awesome and
because there's this big time jump between those
events and her showing up in the mandalorian
series the dave filoni has not filled in yet
canonically it has not been proven that she
learned luke skywalker's identity and did
the mental calculus just connecting him to anakin
skywalker through their last names like maybe this
luke person is related to anakin dave baloney
already confirmed that this scene of ahsoka
picking up sabine wren to go find ezra bridger
happens after the mandalorian season 2 episode 5.
so given what dave filoni has said about the news
story that he's writing for ahsoka tano in live
action through the mandalorian and the big luke
skywalker reveal during the finale episode and
what they're doing with that character this part
of the timeline of course ahsoka tano and luke
skywalker would eventually meet through grogu
in this larger grand admiral thrawn storyline
right now all roads in the star wars universe set
during this part of the timeline the mandalorian
the four spin-off series all lead to grand admiral
thrawn so all the main characters will eventually
be tied up in this thrawn storyline it's just that
the reason that ahsoka tano didn't say luke's name
when she was telling mando about taking grogu to
the jedi temple if tython is because at that point
she probably didn't know who luke was or just was
too preoccupied with finding grand admiral thrawn
to take the time to investigate any claims about
a person who reportedly blew up the death star
and helped kill the emperor like there's a person
running around the galaxy using anakin's last name
who is this person maybe i should investigate
it's one of those questions like why does mando
not know anything about the jedi why does he seem
so oblivious to what's going on with them you have
to imagine a lot of news gets distorted and the
facts change a little by the time that they hear
about this stuff in the outer rim territories but
the whole key to ahsoka and luke skywalker meeting
is grogu because now he's the common thing linking
them ahsoka didn't tell grogu about being anakin
skywalker's padawan when they spoke to each
other grogu only knows that she used to be a jedi
padawan like him during order 66 she also spent
time at the jedi temple on coruscant but when luke
skywalker starts training grogu especially through
the mandalorian season 3 and speaking to him about
his past reading his memories helping him unlock
his lost memories he'd eventually learned who
ahsoka tano is not that she's his father's former
padawan but that she's just another former jedi
out there who's very important someone that luke
skywalker who's trying to rebuild the jedi order
would want to meet he's trying to find every
last jedi and force sensitive person that he
could potentially train as a jedi out there then
once grogu and ahsoka eventually rejoin mando
during this larger grand admiral thrawn fight that
they're building up to ahsoka would learn about
the training that grogu had been receiving from
luke skywalker then knowing that there's another
jedi out there going by the name skywalker would
make her curious enough to investigate and luke
skywalker will also probably come back for more
of the thrawn storyline in the future for very
important stuff not planning on a ton of deep fake
luke running around but then that's the jumping
off point for them to actually meet in person and
then after they deal with the thrawn plot either
in some books or some future story then she starts
helping him jump start his jedi academy and reboot
the jedi order with grogu so to speak you have
to imagine a version of this scene where he was
talking to leia in return of the jedi when he told
her about the truth that they were brother and
sister and he asked her about their mother padme
tell me about our mother when he finally speaks to
ahsoka he can say tell me about my father because
aside from r2d2 ahsoka tano is one of the only
other people who's alive who would be forthcoming
enough to tell him about the life of anakin
skywalker for those asking about r2d2 there's a
lot of questions about this during the mandalorian
finale video that i did so george lucas actually
revealed that canonically r2d2 never had his
memory wiped if you only saw the movies you
probably wouldn't know that because they end
with that scene saying please wipe these droids
memories but for many many years george lucas has
maintained that r2 never actually had his memory
wiped that's always been a bit of a running joke
in the fandom that r2 is the biggest droid in
the star wars universe because he's withholding
all this information because he remembers
everything that happened during the prequels
but everyone let me know in the comments when
do you think that luke and ahsoka will finally
wind up actually meeting during this part of
the timeline and for those of you asking yes i
do hope that they wind up including force ghost
anakin skywalker hayden christensen scenes with
live-action ahsoka during that series when they
do the spin-off reportedly some of the hayden
christensen stuff that he's filming is going to
be for flashback anakin and darth vader during the
obi-wan series and if he's doing that then it's
just as easy to do force ghost anakin during the
ahsoka series and present day there'll be a bunch
more star wars stuff happening really soon so
leave all your video requests in the comments all
the marvel Wandavision episodes are going to start
in the next 10 days i'll be doing weekly episode
videos for that while you wait for everything
everyone click here for my full mandalorian
season 3 video and click here for that obi-wan
kenobi series trailer thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and happy new year!